alors justement vous vous êtes
rencontrés tous les deux sur internet
et lorsque vous êtes vus pour la toute
première fois vous ne saviez pas c'est
vrai que philippe était amputé des
quatre membres
comment est ce que vous avez réagi
lorsque vous vous l'avez découvert et
avait découvert son handicap il ya quoi
je l' ai découvert je me suis dit je
cherchais plutôt des amis plutôt qu'un
compagnon de vie et je me suis dit
pourquoi pas donc je ne savais pas ce
que ça allait engendrer derrière c'est
vrai que pendant un an j'ai pas vraiment
vécu avec film a fait un truc parce que
le premier message que je veux envoyer
j'avais mis une photo avec ma tête faut
pas déconner non plus il ré avec un
large sourire et j'avais dit comme tu le
vois sur la photo j'ai les cheveux dans
le vent mais le vent était trop fort les
et pour trouver écoute si le vent
souffle vers moi je les ramène à vous
saviez déjà pour la calvitie ça démarre
au pied très bien mes petits camarades
sont eux aussi plonger dans ce livre
avec délice et ils ont des questions à
vous poser on va commencer par damien
oui susanna lorsque l'on lit votre livre
en fait on se rend compte que vous êtes
enfin que vous vous êtes très dépendants
en fait de votre mari puisque finalement
vous êtes obligé de l'aider à cause de
son handicap
et forcément ce n'est pas drôle tous les
jours alors quelles sont les difficultés
en fait que vous rencontrez au quotidien
alors qu'antti au quotidien c'est faire
sa toilette c'est surtout si on sort
parce que la maison est aménagé donc y'a
pas de soucis à la maison on a vraiment
tout fait pour que ça soit accessible
c'est plutôt à l'extérieur où quand on
part dans dans les pays étrangers où on
n'a pas l'accès à l'hôtel
quant à l'hôtel les trottoirs qui sont
trop grands enfin tout plein de petites
choses qui qui nous pourrissent la vie
au quotidien au final le bateau les
japonais par tout cas oui c'est ça bah
oui c'est pas forcément évident le
fameux toilettes japonaises
oui c'est vrai ah bah ouais on ressort
plus propre à la sortie qu'à l'entrée et
effectivement on a envie de vous poser
cette question parce que effectivement
philippe pardonnez moi mais vous êtes
plein de vie on se dit en fait ce type
là tout va bien face et voilà c'est il a
pas besoin d aide
et en fait il a besoin d'être malgré cet
allant malgré cet humour malgré ce côté
combattants battant bas c'est tout de
même quelqu'un qui a besoin d aide
voilà c'est quelqu'un qui n'est pas
comme vous voyez les amputés donc c'est
vrai qu'il peut pas utiliser demain donc
c'est nous c'est moi qui suit c'est
maintenant
la raison du livre ma vie pour deux
c'est que je pense aussi pour lui tous
les soirs par exemple un petit exemple
tout banal c'est de préparer sa brosse à
dents pour qu'ils puissent se brosser
les dents ça moi je pense à lui bien sûr
ou plutôt à 8 et après à moi donc de
repenser tout le temps l'un à l'autre en
fait face surtout elle pense surtout à
moi on la lecture entre bien dans le
livre un moment donné j'ai été très
égoïste dormait dans mes défis que soit
la traversée de la manche relier les
cinq continents où le dakar et je
demandais à susanna toujours encore plus
et encore plus et encore plus et je me
rendais pas compte qu'elle était dans la
souffrance parce qu'elle est plein plein
d'amour et plein d'abnégation et et moi
j'avance et tête baissée dans mais dans
mes objectifs et à un moment donné elle
explique très bien dans le livre que
elle craque elle craque elle décide de
partir marcher marcher elle est pas
sportivement plus elle a marché de
fatima jusqu'à saint jacques de
compostelle pendant trois semaines pour
pleurer et pensé se retrouver et bien
sûr et se retrouver sur toi bien sûr
bien évidemment mais parce que vous vous
à vous êtes vous alors vous vous dites à
chaque fois un nouveau défi renouveau
des six puits pour qu'elle suive
derrière quoi il faut que tout le monde
suive derrière est donc un moment donné
sur fatigué donc je les relais mais là
je peux pas la police que c'est ma
chérie doute
une chose qui est très très étonnante
dans votre dans votre livre c'est que
vous parler vraiment de votre vie intime
sans tabou vous dites que vous voulez
rassurer les gens qui sont confrontés au
handicap et vous parlez de votre vie
sexuelle et vous dites que vous avez une
vie sexuelle - très épanouie vous avez
une vie sexuelle très épais évidemment
inconnu razar caroline est tombé sur ce
sujet là car on peut revisiter le kama
sutra voit des gens qui sont un peu
embêtante mais les questions parce que
effectivement rester normal mais voilà
cesana c'est vrai que ces questions
parce que la plupart souvent on a
tendance à dévier et à être j'allais
dire les dents et plus lamoureux oui
amoureuse et donc il c'est important de
réserves en air qui est très fine et
c'est vrai que quand on est en cantonais
dans les entraînements avec philippe bas
c'est surtout et donc il va prendre le
dessus sur la compagne donc voilà il ya
une petite frontère frontières qu'on
dans un temps c'est trop et dans des
fois c'est trop compagne donc il faut
trouver l'équilibré c'est très compliqué
juste d'avoir lieu au bon moment voilà
la première fois qu on a été l'un contre
l'autre avec l'usam 1 à la réaliser un
geste qui moi m'a touché au plus profond
j'ai même craqué j'ai pleuré en plaidant
l'enlever le premier chose qu'elle a
fait elle a pris mon bras gauche chez
mon bras gauche c'est le braquet plus le
plus accidenté elle a pris elle la
caresser ça m'a bouleversé
j'ai craqué j'ai hélas elle m'a libéré
totalement elle m'a complètement libéré
ça m'a fait du bien et c'est ce que je
disais ça va aller ça valait tous les
axes sexuelle du monde le fait qu'elle
prenne mon bras avec elle le caresse et
qu'elle me rassure basse et voilà c'est
tout
[Applaudissements]